Apple CEO Tim Cook is telling CBS
mornings that the world's most valuable
company has slowed some hiring this
follows news that Facebook's parent
company meta slash more than 11 000 jobs
we were on Apple's campus in Cupertino
California for a look at some new
technology for a story that you'll see
tomorrow only on CBS Mornings in our
exclusive interview we asked cook how
economic conditions are affecting his
company
there's been reports that Apple has
frozen hiring in certain areas yeah
where do you see apple as it tries to
navigate this unpredictable economic
future so what we're doing as a
consequence of being in this period is
we're being very deliberate on our
hiring that means we're continuing to
hire but not everywhere in the company
are we hiring we believe strongly in
investing for the long term and we don't
believe you can save your way to
Prosperity we think you invest your way
to it as we were talking off camera you
said it's a beautiful day people are at
work there were people working from home
now you have people returning to work
what did you do to incentivize people
that worked at Apple to show up again
well for us you know we make product of
course and you have to hold product
right you collaborate with one another
because we believe that one plus one
equals three and so that takes the
Serendipity of running into people and
bouncing ideas off and caring enough to
advance your idea through somebody else
because you know that it'll make it a
bigger idea that doesn't mean that we're
going to be in here five days we're not
if you're here on a Friday it would be a
ghost town
you can see our full story tomorrow on
CBS mornings including some of the new
technology in the iPhone 14 that is
absolutely mind-blowing yeah agree agree
with Tim Cook I think you work better
when you can see your people face to
face your colleagues your bosses
everybody I prefer that those
conversations in the hallway over a desk
I mean you don't want them to happen on
a Friday and over wants to know in their
life but I think it does I think it does
increase company's bottom lines and he's
saying that we make a thing you need to
talk about it we need to hold it it
builds that chemistry yeah you know and
I mentioned the the features they are
absolutely mind-blowing life-changing
and then also there's a very unique
approach that Apple has about working
there in the building and then giving
people extended time on the weekend you
want to stick around for this interview
it's going to be great yeah I don't mind
Ghost Town Fridays